[Music]
chemistry explains literally everything
that is happening around you the drive
is taking the thermal energy from the
water unfortunately I instantaneously
get judged on my appearance that is very
frustrating for me so I'm gonna pick up
my hot water I'm gonna come over here
and I'm going to throw it right into my
bucket okay it means I have to work
harder but at the end it is so so
incredibly worth it and one my name is
dr. Katie Bergdorf and I am a lecturer
at the University of Texas at Austin I'm
trying to break the stigma of what a
stereotypical scientist looks like so my
thing is I am NOT wearing a bow tie I'm
not wearing suspenders I don't have some
frumpy cardigan on I'm just some regular
girl who likes to play with fire I also
really like designer shoes and that's
okay as the alginate hits the calcium
chloride the alginate would prefer to be
with the two plus charge calcium instead
of the one plus charge sodium and what
happens is we form gummy worms doesn't
matter what you look like any human can
be a scientist I definitely try to use
energy and excitement I do my best to
try to reach students that might be
intimidated by science I use anything
that will make the four hundred and
eighty three students sit up straight
and actually listen to the words coming
out of your mouth as soon as I've
exploded something in their face I have
their attention for just 60 seconds and
I can do whatever I can to shove that
knowledge right into their brains
okay so what we're gonna do today is
doing some chemistry we're gonna do
three different hands-on experiments I
find chemistry to be an incredibly
challenging topic I am so sick of the
stereotypical female scientists and we
can do things other than biology by the
way chemistry physics engineering we can
do it the fact that I've been able to
master it but then use science to start
the conversation but then physically
stand there and break that image it's
the most rewarding thing I could ever do
ever
[Music]